dobbiamo arrampicarci qua
ma cosa c'entra con il museo
lo zombie
solo sulla luna beneficerà di cantone
ticino esimo per nuovissime skype rombo
c'era più attenta palleggiare la
servizio appena detto qualcosa il suo
neonato desiste riesce a reggere tu cosa
ha detto la guardia dice il museo è
stato abbandonato e dobbiamo scappare
prima che cada binga da un museo
decadente come sempre sarà tradotto con
google translate the broom quindi ci
saranno cose che non avranno senso ma
certamente nel museo ci sono gli aussie
biscotti fatti a forma di osso verità
giusto quindi oggi ho visti perché i
promo e del museo siamo troppo curiosi
di vedere come voi ci fa un albero
diabete nel museo c'è più alberi che
abete guarda ci sono altri
comunque fi mettetevi così freddi pop
corn e stato bello il piano il corpo
abbiamo salvato wow ci sono i pianeti
qua c'è la terra queste marte questo
bonus
saturno blu blu blu che
non lo so genere e questo e quello
giallo andiamo
in porta c'è un missile spaziano una
religione a spaziare un qualcosa voglio
dare l'idea di andare bisogna premere il
bottone vai vai vai abbiamo ben premi
bottone per aprire le scale ed entrare
nel raggio dai napoletani
rotare entreremo nel razzo e
premi hugo nello spazio
e con le scale si aprono sotto un abito
piaci carnaval altri personaggi
siamo sulle scale e dove sei non ti
resta che
presto entrerà o che figo
il razzo stampare
solo sulla luna
wow abbiamo perso la gravità guarda
benissimo e io voglio rimanere qua siamo
guardo solo in questo buco nero però non
cado è un cratere un protetto volevo
dire non un buco nero della mia per la
luna chelsea sono delle navi
schiantati riguarda bisogna salire su
con l'alcol a forza di gravità con la
mia non c'è la gravità poi nel senso
senza gravità bisogna saltare si sale su
in alto una
bellissima
promesso per bella
qualcuno si è riconosciuto nella stato
ha speso o michael ii you tube
ogni tanto capita che nelle skype room
che facciamo ci siete anche voi
bellissimo perché ci salutiamo magari
lei sa è difficile incontrarsi perché ci
sono tipo 10.000 escape lug sul rob lowe
ti volevo giusto tirare attento quando
stati sopra c'è la supervelocità
attivata già che mi straccerò molte
volte adesso adesso acceleri extra
iazzetta prendiamo
petrolio è buttato no non mi sono
buttato sono solo quando si ha fortuna
scivolare in un altra parte di tutti che
finora non ci siamo sfracellati vuole
vogliono evitare ciò che poteva essere
una gomma li sta colando da qualche
parte una gomma rosa vedi non credo che
come non coma ma poi cosa intendi con
gomma da masticare
strage di rho e che vi sono partiti
cappello barrique se è così io
sono io quello ciao quella sei tu
antonio non altro di un'altra nave posto
la zucca estrarre comunque ti volevo
dire che da qui dove sono io si vede il
castello
no non mi dire che c'è un caffè no
settimo il castello il classe blu
castello disney no
insieme a ragione nel senso era proprio
fighissimo come che brighi 6 pro quasi
seguite da tanto sapete che le mie fip
room
[Musica]
legni e ski promo preferite sono quelle
nei cassetti
[Musica]
ti ricordi quella col drago è una delle
mie che forse la mia poker room
preferita ha avuto
ve lo ricordate le stime un contraggo
che si trasformavano in galline ma
facevano nome di vita o magari lo avete
visto e volete rivederla vi lascio la
castellina alla fine di questo video per
rivedere quella bellissima e scritto
rombo che fa troppo ridere ma ora ha
sbrigato dieci carri non è possibile che
io non so cosa sia vanta e dice la gomma
da masticare ma sono ancora sfracellato
e tu stai ancora così e se ancora la
somma da masticare se cioè io sono
arrivato al castello già
speriamo che ci sia un brano mai visto
il castello da lì si vede
ma come mandi a casa chi si assomiglia
c'è il torrione delle ferite ancora
tutto
l'oro blu tv
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il termine
però mai a parole dure puoi farcela
tecnologico dirigendo a 100 come volevo
andare d'acqua
a righe i conti volevo solo dire che
quelle che arriveranno dopo saranno
sempre più difficile bisogna saltare suo
popolo questi muri minuscoli per i
sembrano delle stalagmiti
si guarda sono questi erano che serve
ora capisco visto vitale legge sui
pentiti piccol poi della mancanza di
gravità sono così no mi chiedo allora
mettiamoci qui prepariamo una cesta di
pop corn e aspettiamo la vanità che si
sfracelli 187 mila volte la stessa cosa
starà cercando di capire che tipo di
castello è
dai forse sì ce l'ha punita da una barra
sa cosa salta salta in alto no no devo
saltare di nave che cosa stai dicendo
disfacendo andiamo a saltar qui vedi ma
poi dopo non riesce a salire
non solo rendiconto di stato non ci
arrivo in alto ruggeri proprio perché
ormai è sbagliata la briga e quindi ma
ora mi ritrovo a marika trova aspetta
guarda ma forse così e di una
piattaforma che questo incidente
stradale
non ce la farà mai mai
in un universo parallelo si è pagato il
gioco del mio personaggio sta sbagliando
che pur elevata devo raggiungere il
cappello molto piano ma tutto daccapo
dovuto iniziare non ci voglio credere
ma non è tutto daccapo
29 days later
[Musica]
basta perché non avete lasciato vi piace
la sera mi piace per portargli fortuna
ok ragazzi sono arrivata fa in quella
parte difficile devo a concentrazione
sopra la corrente sembra un poco più in
là devi andare spostati per la allora
adesso priva di forza ecco come più la
roma però se manca privi trovate al ri
troppo presto e ci sembra segnare
l'ultimo bye bye bye bye ancora ancora
ancora pro
aspetta non potete saltare ma era ancora
vai avanti va avanti ecco vitale ciao
sono qui
[Musica]
perché scarpine dello stato dai bravi ce
l'ha fatta
sono passate tipo centro 17 ore
in casa è la tecnologica nove gli
allievi sembra più una miscela una
navicella spaziale
ma questo forse la stazione spaziale
detta il muro l'ho capito bene stazione
spaziale questa che bene ci siamo
arrivati ball missing navicella spaziale
fatta forma di missile ha visto non ho
visto grazie
ma dove dobbiamo andiamo adesso gli
utenti di qua
ok il muro passato teca dove aspetta che
devono stare
ma poi il pericolo più mestiere
ciao ciao
sono già avanti ha salvato ciao ciao
italia
vanno sempre più bravo
torneo che bello sono sfracellato per la
prima volta
le rare museale regole giusto dopo aver
esplorato tutta la parte della città è
tutto tutto tutto
è vitale ritorna in vantaggio per tutta
la parte relativa allo spazio adesso te
ne volute che figari odore musei ad ora
esplorare i musei
ma qui c'è tipo frankestein che quassù
questo liquido verde eccolo lì dove di
rientro con il museo
uno zombie ma vediamo si possa prendere
la supervelocità da qui no non si può
prendere una bella tu stavi cercando da
mangiare in questo distributore fatto
abbiamo questi laser la forma di lingua
ecco perciò il museo si è stato preso
d'assalto da
questo sono degli zombie marinai che non
solo con i marinai che sono stati
presidente di un paio di video fa ti
ricordi
capitanata da avete visto il video con
il marinaio
sera l'avete visto dopo questo video
andate a vederlo chiuso il link nella
casellina finale aiuti prima data sopra
dai viveri guarda viventi sono qui ciao
o che bene mettendo all'alto guardate
certo che è bellissimo hanno perso un
pezzo del movimento sul piano di sopra
di questo moscati permetteremo di questi
travi di legno così tra zombie burn o no
che è successo che c'è non lo so ma
senza di qua
velocità sono stati risucchiati in un
universo parallelo guarda siamo in
un'altra area e tv 1 al 3 skype room
questa non si capisce no è sempre la
stessa perché siamo allo stage 11 è come
se sì forse come di stato un universo
bar ha detto dal gruppo dell'universo
parallelo dai facciamo la gara che
arriva prima
il problema sono super forte voi per chi
fate il tifo per l'italia
anzi per berlino
carrozziere lì per dormendo quel
patatone berlino dome tantissimi sta
dormendo nel divano
nov italia in vantaggio visto
che aveva fatto da crociera per svitare
polverizzato mi hai fatto a passare a
tutti che sicuramente perché non bisogna
toccare le parti scure è poi così devo
andare io
non bisogna contare le parti scure no no
no no no tanto che soddisfacenti urlare
ancora
giù ha fatto primario ma chi è a farla
quella linea è stata tipo un giorno e
mezzo di chino sui primi sui primi non
lo so
infine sempre mi stage come si dice la
gara era sono per questo
no la maledizione degli strusciamenti mi
sto progettando sempre adesso per la
preghiera da
scoprire che cosa
ti raggiungerò
avvenne nel museo eppure caduta l'acqua
sia un problema idraulico o legato al
museo ci sono tanti problemi in questo
video ma forse per quello che l'hanno
abbandonato
[Musica]
eccomi tar e questa volta la si
sfracella mi sono preso lato tribale
saldo ma che cosa dice lui
e ai rami per attraversare ok ma
dobbiamo arrampicarci quale
vitale ha capito bene le istruzioni per
caduto verranno dai è facile
[Musica]
dai tavoli mi piace un sacco questo
script promesso per karina poi alla fine
del video scrivete nei commenti che voto
gli dati da una di esse
che cosa dice
questa stanza si sta rompendo sarà meno
salta sopra i ladri hanno fatto in tempo
nel vecchio
dinosauro
scheletro del di nota è stata anche
carino ma non mi rechero
non lo so se proprio dobbiamo
affrontarli dinosauri tempo bellissimo
aria avevo paura che ci mangiasse poi
dopo che avete capito insomma m
beh effettivamente
36 vitale libro non è caduto
pensavo fossero delle pizze ma non
dobbiamo queste cose che si muovevano
considerano rotonde delle pizze ma come
hai fatto vedere delle piste
quello che sono tipo dei laser sono dei
falliti certa a dei fari erano di fare
tipo che si muovono così io rido per
evitare che si sfracella e poi
distruggerli il fratello antonio il
piano
non possiamo andare avanti così ci
salviamo
noi ha vinto ce lo puoi farcela
brava sosta sorta ok proprio piano
pronto per la sua tecnica bye bye salta
sopra al 36 però adesso dobbiamo salire
su arrampicarci ai e poi io spero solo
che non sia un labirinto questo perché
avere anche i venti che mi perdo noi
siamo
ci sono le mostre di casa no non
bisognava stare qui certi punti a gara
mentre trasportava soffre a trovare
adesso a ecco dovevamo girare qua
giustamente sono più conosce sua voce
da
raggiungere vitale si raggiunge nome di
un po di rincorsa 6 ottenuto dai laser
laser lava e tipo questo perché sembra
poco ma se però forma di lana o no poi
ci sono i preferiti di anita il laser
che si muovono in alto in basso
non è un pregiudizio varie volte in
questi è la terminata inaspettato
via
[Musica]
la situazione ok se guarda
che furba che se si passa davanti a
una cella ma scusa ma perché queste
gomme da masticare sono giganti quali
restano per terra e quello della
macchinetta solo piccolissima
dove sono verità
ogni tanto finiscono al limbo ok dai che
sono puoi fare no
allora con calma a roviano poi a
sbagliare queste cose così semplice
la pioggia volo da milano e mezzo come
fai altro parla dentro la vita devo
prendere un'altra strada ma salta non
passano libra è così difficile
se volevamo resta guardare blair
anche potito dice ce l'abbiamo fatta usa
il teletrasporto per andare non so dove
è allora aspettiamo il petto innanzi
tutto
confermato wow
wow collezionato finora con tutte le
scritte room che abbiamo fatto sacconi
possiamo vedere forza e un giorno vi
faremo vedere tutto anche ma prima
voglio entrare in questa casa il quale
caso è chiuso questa casa è finta obi
questo caso vediamo che altresì pronto
ci propone le abbiamo provate tutte che
un'amica questo è un cane che sta
mangiando qualcuno quella era quello del
veterinario
contestate in quello poi versato
ginevrina ancor prima successo sono
atterrato da un'altra parte che bella
quesito lei ma un isoletta tipo vincevo
dove possiamo dare i giusti vedere se il
rumore wow
che proceda orafi la somma 4 castellini
su cui cliccare per vedere tutte altri
delicata su quello che preferite buona
visione ciao